the ecb
and all national central banks in the
euro system
will implement decisively and rigorously
all the sanctions decided by the eu and
the european governments
to give you an example that will apply
to supervision that will apply with
cutting off liquidity access for the
targeted banks with the view to
essentially freeze our set
and starve access to finance what we
know is that the two main channels
through which
the euro area economy will be affected
will be through energy
prices
and through the confidence or
uncertainty channel not so much through
trade which is limited between russia
and the euro area
on energy gas and oil prices soared on
russia's invasion of ukraine given the
role of russia as energy supplier
roughly 22.2 percent of the uh euro area
energy imports
at this point in time gas prices
stand about six times six times as high
as one year ago
and oil prices 54 percent higher than
one year ago we helped to reduce our
dependency from russia's supply we need
to diversify
uh already when we were faced with a
price uh hike of
of energy which was primarily driven by
high uh prices of natural gas
uh european uh commission put on table
proposals on uh organizing a joint
natural gas procurement organizing a
strategic
natural gas reserve
in order to
be more immune
against possible
manipulations energy market
manipulations by russia so uh we are uh
also assessing the question of natural
gas from the uh opposite angle
what happens for example if russia
decides to cut off gas supplies as a
retailer reaction for example
and our assessment is that
not without problems but we will be able
to manage there have been number of
steps which had been taken in
recent months and weeks to
to allow this
situation